Paris thank you and we've been watching
these pictures on the Drone and Eagle
Pass there are more and more gathering
before that barbed wire and Griff
Jenkins is right there Griff what have
you heard as you've talked to these
migrants today hello
well Bill we want to give you a look
here right along the razor wire more
than 50 migrants over here gathered some
women with small children and you can
see here over here along the razor wire
you've got the Texas DPS in the National
Guard stopping the migrants from coming
through the razor de dondeas
you can hear that bill Venezuela most of
them are from Venezuela and actually
here right at the very close next to the
no trespassing city of Eagle Pass you
can see two women stuck in the razor
wire here behind me hola
comatama
Anna
Anna's aura
opportunity that she says her name is
Anna from Venezuela says it's coming
bill for an opportunity that's the scene
right here we'll see whether or not
border patrol comes and cuts the wire as
we've seen them in past stage two to let
these migrants through right now it's a
standoff Bill send it back to you that
has been the pattern to cut the wire
thank you Griff Eagle Pass thank you